♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
According
to The Washington Post,
President Biden exercises
most mornings
by lifting weights
before he begins work.
That makes sense
because he is clearly
not using the StairMaster.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry, but the clip is fun.
He's fine.
[ Laughter ]
According to
The Washington Post,
President Biden occasionally
goes to the South Lawn
or Rose Garden during the day
to get fresh air
with his dogs, Champ and Major,
while the rest of the staff
goes literally anywhere else.
Somebody commented me
that it's time
to stop making fun
of Major biting people.
I feel like a year.
He has to go a year
without biting anyone.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said on Friday
that he would not allow
the Justice Department
to seize the phone records
of journalists.
Well, that explains
Matt Gaetz's new hat.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden has reportedly
continued a tradition,
started
by former President Obama,
of reading ten letters
each night
that are sent to the White House
by individual Americans.
Though, in the Obama days,
they were mostly from Joe.
[ Laughter ]
Former Vice President Mike Pence
and former
Second Lady Karen Pence
have reportedly purchased a new
home outside of Indianapolis.
And, of course,
it was outside the city
because you know this guy
doesn't go downtown.
[ Laughter ]
Baze!
Alex Baze,
as I live and breathe!
[ Laughter ]
A New York librarian
was arrested last Friday
for allegedly robbing a bank.
Well, trying to, at least.
[ Whispering ]
Okay, everyone hit the floor.
[ Laughter ]
Because they'd whisper
outside the library.
[ Laughter ]
That's the thing
about librarians.
People think it's
about the library.
It's fundamentally inside them.
It was announced last week
that Pope Francis
will get a new
electric Popemobile.
Of course, before he can plug
the charger into the outlet,
they have to get married.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
dogs can effectively detect
the coronavirus
with 97% accuracy,
which is great news because
that's the only provider
in your network.
Scientists reported that the
largest iceberg in the world
broke off from Antarctica
last week
and it's roughly 70 times
larger than Manhattan.
Yeah, but I bet they don't have
any good restaurants.
And, finally, yesterday was
Lucky Penny Day.
Right, because who's luckier
than Abraham Lincoln?
[ Laughter ]
Look, I don't have to read
the Mike Scollins jokes.
I get that.
[ Laughter ]
But, if I didn't,
you wouldn't know
what I'm putting up with,
day in and day out.
[ Laughter ]
"If you see something,
say something."
♪♪
The National Guard yesterday
began withdrawing troops
from the U.S. Capitol following
a five-month deployment
after the January insurrection.
Which is strange,
considering they didn't even get
all the insurrectionists
out, yet.
The White House announced
today that the U.S. has
officially vaccinated 50%
of its adult population
and they expect that,
by the end of September,
they will have vaccinated
the other 7% or 8%.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, the White House
announced today that the U.S.
has officially vaccinated
50% of its adult population,
as well as one 11-year-old
with a mustache.
[ Laughter ]
"Uh, could I get a Moderna
and a case of
Mike's Hard Lemonade?
[ Laughter ]
Whose Schwinn is that outside?
So lame!"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
is expected to meet
with Russian President
Vladimir Putin
next month in Switzerland
for their first
face-to-face summit
or, you know, face-to-chest.
I just hope it does not come
down to a staring contest
because both of those guys
have had a lot of Botox.
Could be a long one.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
announced yesterday
that Secretary of State
Tony Blinken
will travel this week to Israel
to discuss the cease-fire
between Israel and Hamas.
Okay, can we send someone
a little more intimidating?
Tony Blinken looks like a guy
who thinks your mom's
a real special lady,
but isn't trying
to replace your dad.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
yesterday signed a law
regulating social media
companies' moderation
of user speech.
Said Twitter,
"Sir, that's just --
it's just spell-check."
Vice President Kamala Harris
said yesterday
that broadband Internet is
"critical to infrastructure"
and then, Spectrum added
a 30-cent critical
to infrastructure fee.
[ Laughter ]
Google announced last week
it will open its first-ever
physical retail store
this summer in New York
and get this --
Tinder already did.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Google announced last week
it will open its first-ever
physical retail store
this summer in New York,
although, it will be weird
to ask a salesperson a question
and get 1.3 million answers.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida woman who was wearing
nearly no clothing
was arrested over the weekend
after she allegedly stole a car
and led authorities
on a high-speed chase.
And to give you an idea
what Florida's like,
the police in Florida refer
to that as a code 1.
A bank robbery is a code 2.
According to new research,
a day on Venus lasts
nearly 6,000 hours.
"So, same as Earth?"
asked Amazon workers.
And, finally, producers have
announced that a documentary
about lifestyle expert
Martha Stewart
will stream on Netflix.
And, if you don't have
a Netflix account,
she'll show you how to make one
out of driftwood and corn husks.
♪♪
The Manhattan district attorney
has reportedly convened
a grand jury
that is expected to decide
whether to indict
former President Trump.
God, imagine that arrest.
"You have
the right to an attorney.
But, as a friend,
I wouldn't recommend it."
Former President Trump said
on his website today
that his administration
is the reason
for low coronavirus cases
and successful vaccine rollout
in the U.S.,
which is sort of like
the captain of the Hindenburg
saying,
"Don't forget who got us
off the ground."
Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
is facing criticism
after tweeting
that coronavirus
vaccine passports
and mask mandates
are just like
Nazis forcing Jewish people
to wear a gold star.
It's the first time she's wanted
people to be undocumented.
A junior high principal
in Arkansas apologized recently
after the school's yearbook
featured a photo
of former President Donald Trump
with the caption,
"President Trump
was not impeached."
He also apologized for the claim
that Trump was...
According to a new study,
researchers believe
that the maximum age
a human could physically reach
is 150 years old.
"Challenge accepted,"
said the U.S. Senate.
Former baseball player
Alex Rodriguez
recently launched a line
of concealer for men,
and then men tried
to put it on wedding rings.
[ Laughter ]
I tried -- I tried to do the --
deliver it
the way I feel Jenny
would have wanted me to.
[ Laughter ]
"And then men..."
According to a new study,
relocating wolves
to areas with frequent
car accidents caused by deer
can reduce collisions by 24%,
which almost makes up
for the 3,000% increase
in wolf attacks.
[ Laughter ]
According to a recent survey,
the average American believes
they can survive for 16 days
in the wilderness,
adding, "Wait,
what's the Wi-Fi password?"
Today is World Redhead Day,
but then the sun came out
and they had to cancel.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new report,
poison control centers
in the U.S. experienced
a significant increase
in marijuana-related calls
between 2017 and 2019,
and they always started
the same way.
Hello?
What's the emergency?
"Hello? Who is this?"
Man, you called me.
♪♪
President Biden yesterday
called on China
to participate in a, "full,
transparent, evidence-based,
internal investigation to find
the origins of COVID-19."
Said China,
"Honestly, can this wait?
We are just slammed
with COVID-21.
Or, I mean, sure, no problem."
That's right, President Biden
called on China to participate
in an investigation to find
the origins of COVID-19,
and I just got to say,
if it's not bats,
we owe them a major apology.
It's going to be like one of
those double jeopardy scenarios
where they've been wrongfully
blamed for a crime,
so now they really do get
to start a pandemic.
According to a new report,
former President Trump
tried to intervene in 2008
to stop the investigation
of the New England Patriots'
so-called "Spygate" scandal.
Wait, he was involved
in that scandal, too?
He's like the Forrest Gump
of scandals.
Next, we're going to find out he
was one of the 1919 Black Sox.
British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson
reportedly considered getting
the coronavirus injected
in his body
on live TV last summer
because he thought the virus
wasn't a threat.
Who are you, Prime Minister
Johnny Knoxville?
Boris Johnson's
the only UK leader
to come with his own
theme music.
[ "Jackass" theme song playing ]
[ Laughter ]
The Recording Academy yesterday
announced changes
to the Grammy Awards'
nomination process.
That's right --
you can now be nominated
if you're Taylor Swift
or Beyoncé.
Today was Republican Congressman
Marjorie Taylor Greene's
47th birthday, which is also
the only accurate information
on her Facebook page.
That's right, today was
Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene's
47th birthday.
And if you're wondering
what to get her, how about help?
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]